- I know this person
better than I know myself.
- I know her better than she knows me
knowing herself.
- We've known each other
for about a year and a half.
We spend 40 hours minimum
a week together at work.
- We're together 100 percent of the time
all the time everyday 24/7.
- This is going to tear
apart our relationship.
- I know.
- If we're with new people, it'll be like,
hi, Mike Ferman.
How you doing?
Or if it's our friends, it's like this,
first he starts talking like this.
It's very lightly.
Ahh.
- You enjoy having your
hands out like this.
- What?
Oh.
- Like, okay, guys so what
I usually do like that is,
yeah.
- She does almost like a baby character
where she'll be like,
are you okay, Gabby?
Are you sad?
- I'm Kelsey Darrah and I have everything
and then she's like,
but I'm not a comedienne.
I'm not funny.
- I'm just really stressed out right now.
I've got like 28 videos to do
and the white supremacy
is still holding me back.
We didn't get that answer
to that question we asked,
did we?
No we didn't.
- Can you believe that
this person wrote that?
I mean, I follow them on Twitter
and they didn't follow me back.
She'll either be shouting at you
or talking where she's
pretending to listen
but she's not because she's on her phone.
So I could be like,
I'm going to space today
and she'd be like, yeah.
Of course, yeah.
- Kelsey gets very aggressive.
You don't understand what this costs.
She like points and her
fingers are like bullets.
- When I see you stress out,
you still smile just like in
a really shady ass way like.
- So when you're fighting with Gabby,
instead of being her
normal boisterous self,
she shuts down to make
you feel very guilty
and just sort of looks at the floor.
Well, I guess I just didn't
expect this to happen today.
- You're like an old southern lady.
You're like, what you did last night
was totally fine by me but
that's none of my business.
Bless her heart.
- I am so sick of this.
I'm just over it.
My hair is standing up.
His hair literally stands
up when he's stressed out.
- If I criticize something
that's in left field,
she'll be like, okay so I'm a bad person.
It becomes a very personal like,
fine, you hate me.
Everyone hates me.
And it's like, nobody hates you.
- We don't drink.
- That's it.
- Gabby hates admitting that she's drunk
and I think she's so
worried about losing control
that you become boring.
- Kelsey, I can't.
I can't, Kelsey.
And it's always like you're like,
shots for everyone on me.
No, I got this.
Don't be ridiculous.
- Allison becomes the
best person I've ever met.
She's just like everybody's best friend.
Hey, how you doing?
She's so funny.
You can't leave me.
Don't leave me.
Are you leaving?
You can't leave me.
I love you.
Don't leave me.
- She'll be sitting down and
we're having a nice dinner
and she's like, I'm just going to have
a couple glasses of wine, girl.
It's going to be fine.
Wine after wine and
she's like, I love you.
I love life.
I'm doing so good.
And literally, she'll put her head down.
She'll just be like, oh my
God, everything's great.
She'll be like this and then be like augh.
Fuck, I hate everything.
I'm going to kill someone.
- Last Christmas party, she was like this.
She was doing a lot of this.
You enjoy grabbing
like grabbing by the hand a lot like that.
- Yes, I do that.
- And then like that.
Yes.
(laughing)
- For someone who's so
confident in their body
and sexually expressive,
no moves.
- It's like an old person at a party.
- Yeah, it's just like.
- Chris likes to do this
thing where he's like
and he looks down and
does this cute thing.
- Like this like really intense
and she won't let go for the whole song.
She's just like.
- Yeah.
- One time, she was doing this
to a Fifth Harmony song
and then she just went,
if you don't commit,
what are you doing?
- It's fun to know from other people
what you do, I guess.
- I never would have
realized that's how I fight
until you pointed it out to me.
- Whatever.
I like the way you do your weird shit
because that's what makes you you.
(light music)